par jeu souffre d'un trouble d'identité
ma culture était noyée mes racines
enterrer la langue par ma grand-mère
était cousue à mon palais pour que je ne
puisse la parler négritude créolité des
mots barbares qu'avant je ne pouvais
prononcer ils ont fait passer langue
pour un dialecte ou un baragouin ce sont
des peuples sans mémoire donc son futur
que l'on obtient car si tu ne sais pas
où tu viens à quelle grande famille tu
appartiens
je ne peux pas évoluer et approprié les
richesses détient c'est la pauvreté de
l'âme comme l'asphyxient provoquée par
la compression de visage dans un compte
sans air pas de racine sow racines pas
tarder ressent arbres pâtit je ne sais
si j'aurai la force de la marque cherche
aujourd'hui n'y ait qu'une population
puisse mettre en écriture ses réflexions
ses hypothèses ses suggestions celui
couple nerfs de la communication c'est
le forcer à se dire qu'il n'a pas droit
à l'émancipation
c'est un crime abject aux colons d'hier
est aujourd'hui goethe et il est créole
qui suivent par les ténèbres deschamps
nous qu'à vivre en bâtiment les ventes
et les volets de culture nos l'oeil aux
vivants pouillot prise waziers nous au
moment du soulèvement qui soulèvement
les funérariums se construisent en
bordure des zones industrielles
l'université adossé au multiplexe on se
restaure sur le terre plein des
échangeurs la faillite des boutiques
aliments bérillon 10 15
nos marges se réduisent et du centre
ville
j'emprunte la navette qui m'emmène à la
gare ferroviaire
la pelouse du stade a poussé entre les
barres de tours l'entreprise voisine
entrepôts ces engins mécaniques à l'abri
d'un grillage
le parti est encore en chantier la
brochure distribuée à la gare permet de
s'y repérer et on achète des légumes
vente directe sur les déboires de la
nationale 7 arrêts bref plus loin encore
des grossistes de jouer se rassemblent à
l'endroit où le périphérique peur
fabricant d'utilitaires en émail dans sa
baraque de tôle en rase campagne espace
déchargement des containers à l'arrière
de la gare et quelques gouttes de sang
sur un téléobjectif vision de jour les
graffeurs préfère les endroits isolés
d'abord aidés combien elle recouvre un
zèle dit viens s'allonge et ne dit rien
il malaxe c'est simple les ppri dès
demain elle ne dit rien jenny four dans
la charge
edwy du team 100 yards elle ne dit rien
ou quand ils crachent la purée elle
pense enfin se lave les fesses et
retournera pas sur la lune qu'il observe
fume un joint une marche et la rejoindre
d'un pas fait l'un
elle ne dit rien elle en a pas besoin
quand il n'y a pas d'hommes à qui dire
bien acquis dit robien